fun question up top if you guys got
shunted into a parallel universe and you
could save one time travel multiverse
time loop movie to remain exactly the
way it is that you love it in this
universe which one would it be
there will be blood okay Wow
just came to me in a vision it's amazing
thank you that's very intense
I know like I don't know I really like
out of obligation and respect I'm gonna
go with Grandma okay so fair that's nice
it's a good choice nobody picked your
own yeah I'm saying that's to all that
we could so yeah a narcissistic parent
no I was thinking about it you're a
master of promotion or respect yeah well
of course so for you guys when it came
to this film was it something that you
realized early on that happy deathday
had the possibility to be such an
expansive franchise or was it later on
in the making of it it was if you
imagine we did the first movie it's like
I could seat enemies honestly we nobody
thought of a sequel yeah I think it
wasn't the actually the reverse I mean I
definitely obviously we make a lot of
movies sometimes we never make I think
is a huge mistake to make a original
movie only if you can think about the
sequel is I think it's terrible but
definitely of more of most of the movies
that we've done the least likely to have
a sequel would definitely have been this
movie this movie and actually Paranormal
Activity I know that's pretty sure the
other movie that's a very true yeah we
yeah there was there was no there was no
conversation about a sequel while we
were making this movie and and it wasn't
until when I was in post and editing and
almost done where I suddenly was struck
by an idea and I got so excited by the
possibility of the idea that I
to Jason and he got really excited about
it too and I think we all all that
excitement came from the fact that it
was not going to be the same movie like
that we were going to do something
really unexpected and different and
really fun so that was that was the
genesis of it I think you guys pulled it
off and when you open up the gates to a
multiverse all of a sudden you have
every possibility at your disposal since
you wrote that in does your mind run
away with other possibilities or do you
feel like you've done it now I mean it's
it's definitely you could easily go that
direction and it is a bit of a rabbit
hole but I if I am lucky enough
fortunate enough to make a third movie
I'll just say that it's not going to be
that expected path well this is
certainly yeah and I think that's the
important thing is that it's always
about keeping everybody on their toes
and subverting expectations and
challenging yourself as a filmmaker to
do something differently I'm curious if
you guys have a theory I don't have one
but between this spider-verse Russian
doll just went up on Netflix multiverse
type thinking is really in right now in
these projects generally don't happen
overnight it's like in the consciousness
for some reason do you have a theory on
why people are really into this type of
story yeah I think everybody wishes that
we were in an alternate dimension in it
or better I think that the world feels
tumultuous more than more than than ever
at least more than in a long long time
at least from my generation so yeah I
mean I think that there's this idea of
like we know that maybe there's a
there's a better version of our of our
world and our lives out there it's kind
of fun
to fantasize about it okay I could lean
into that theory as well exactly
[Music]